supongamos que estamos en una fábrica de
zapatos mira esta de acá es la fábrica y
estos son los zapatos y queremos
encontrar el mejor número de miles de
pares de zapatos que queremos hacer para
optimizar nuestras ganancias entonces
déjame ponerle por acá que x es igual al
número de miles miles de pares de
zapatos de pares de zapatos de zapatos
producidos producidos y está muy bien
entonces tenemos que ver cuál es el
número óptimo para producir entonces al
producir cierta cantidad de zapatos
tenemos un gasto y tenemos un ingreso y
imaginemos que está dado por la
siguiente fórmula abarth empezamos con
el ingreso vamos a ponerle r al ingreso
del inglés revenue porque ponerle y es
como raro entonces le ponemos r y
supongamos que cada par lo vendemos a 10
pesos entonces para que no nos quede muy
fe esta función vamos a ponerla también
en miles de pesos miles de pesos
de pesos pesos y de esta forma como cada
par se vende a 10 pesos aquí hay que
ponerle 10 x entonces si vendemos por
ejemplo da más mil zapatos entonces aquí
tendríamos 10.000 bueno mil pares de
zapatos aquí teníamos 10 mil pesos esto
está en miles de pesos muy bien entonces
esto quiere decir que bueno si aquí
poner la x hay compradores que están
dispuestos a comprarte todos los padres
que produzcas bueno vamos a pasar ahora
al costo el costo es un poquito más
delicado porque pues no sé o sea tienes
que considerar a los trabajadores y si
produces muchos zapatos entonces para
cobrar para das pero no sólo
proporcionalmente sino mucho más la
máquina también te desgasta éste tienes
que contratar a los analistas para que
te den el precio y supongamos que ya
después de un rato le piensan analizan
los datos y se dan cuenta que el costo
de producir x miles de pares de zapatos
es de x al cubo menos 6 x al cuadrado
más 15
x miras y aquí lo pones x igual a 0 aquí
te queda 0 de ingresos x igual a 0 acá
todo esto se hace cero también te queda
cero de costo no se ve razonable
y estoy acá también estén miles miles de
pesos vale ok entonces si quisiéramos
encontrar la ganancia únicamente
considerando estos datos podemos que
esto es lo único que nos importa pues lo
que tendríamos que hacer es tomar el
ingreso y restarle lo que nos costó
bueno entonces vamos a hacer eso vamos a
poner el eje de ganancia y entonces gdx
va a ser igual a 10 x lo que obtenemos
10 x menos vamos a ponerle menos menos
el costo si el costo entonces sería
menos x al cubo menos x al cubo más 6x
cuadrada menos 15 x si verdad sí sí
restó 6x cuadrada y luego le pongo un
menos se hace más menos 15 x menos 15 x
ok entonces simplificando tantito esto
nos queda igual a igual vamos a poner
este primero - x al cubo
luego el cuadrado más 6x cuadrada y
luego 10 x 15 x es menos 5x excelente
entonces para encontrar pues el máximo
de ganancia que podemos obtener tenemos
que encontrar los puntos críticos de
esta función es decir tenemos que
derivar y ver donde no se define la
derivada o bien donde la derivada es
igual a cero entonces estoy acá es g de
x y déjame pasar de este lado para
platicar de la derivada para entonces
vamos a ponerle por acá g prima de x
prima de x entonces derivando este 3
baja nos queda menos 3x cuadrada luego
nos queda el mal 2 baja más 12 x y luego
nos queda menos 5 vale esta de aquí es
la derivada esta de aquí siempre se vale
verdad o sea no hay ningún valor de x
que nos divida entre 0 o no hay ningún
conflicto en ese sentido entonces esto
siempre está definido así para poder
optimizar esta g lo que necesitamos es
ver dónde esta función se hace igual a
cero entonces vamos a encontrar los
valores de x para los cuales menos 3x
cuadrada
+ 12 x menos 5 es igual a 0
cómo le hacemos para determinar estos
pues mira es una ecuación cuadrática
afortunadamente sabemos resolverlas
verdad con la fórmula general entonces
déjame poner aquí abajo la fórmula
general
vamos a ponerla con este color azul
clarito entonces tenemos que x x es
igual a menos b - 12 + menos raíz
cuadrada va a poner así raíz cuadrada de
b cuadrada 144 menos 4 x a porsche haber
es menos -4 ok menos por menos es más
por menos es menos entonces es menos 4
por 3 por 5 / todo esto dividido
entre dos veces entre menos seis menos
seis muy bien entonces estos son los
valores déjame simplificar un poquito
esto de aquí es igual a mira este menos
con este menos se hace más y este menos
con este más menos pues se convierte en
más menos respectivamente entonces voy a
ponerlo como 12 más menos raíz de aquí
de 144 menos 4 por 33 12 12 por 5 de 60
144 menos 60 es 84 dividido entre entre
6 otra vez lo de menos fue que esté
menos se fue con este menos y este más
menos de todas formas quedan más menos
al dividirse entre menos bueno entonces
tenemos estos números y acá va ahora
estos son dos valores verdades más
déjame o saber ver cuáles son para tener
un poco más de ideas concretas pues
vamos a sacar la calculadora y
aprendemos la aprendemos y entonces
queda 12 más raíz de 84 entre 6 12 más
second raíz de 84 ok creo que aquí sería
bueno ponerle un paréntesis vamos a
enfrentar un paréntesis y dividimos
entre 6 enter entonces es 3.52 75 como
está en mí les voy a agarrarme tres
decimales va entonces es 3.5 528 3.528
3.528 entonces x un valor es 3.5 528
esto es cuando le ponemos el signo + y
la otra posibilidad para x es que x sea
con el signo menos déjame agarrarla la
misma entrada no es lo que quería la
misma entrada entonces es 12 - menos
raíz de 84 en 36 enter
entonces es punto 4 724 va entonces
vamos a ponerle punto 47 25 porque
estamos redondeando hacia arriba va
punto 47 25 entonces es 0.47 25
muy bien ya tenemos dos posibilidades
estos dos son los puntos críticos pero
nosotros queremos maximizar la ganancia
entonces necesitamos ver si estos puntos
nos dan un máximo a ciertos puntos nos
dan un mínimo para eso vamos a pasar
ahora al criterio de la segunda derivada
entonces para eso voy a poner la segunda
derivada en este color azul la segunda
derivada en evaluar en x es igual a ésta
la primera derivada es menos 3x cuadrada
más 2x menos cinco derivando otra vez
nos queda menos 6x menos 6x más 12
sale estar acá es la segunda derivada
entonces qué sucede si le ponemos x
igual a 3.528 y 0.47 25 se podría sacar
la calculadora pero para no hacerlo
podemos estimar más o menos entonces
cuando x es igual a 3.5 28 que obtenemos
pues es mira aquí es menos 6 x pues más
o menos 3.5 6 por 5 es 36 por 318 con 3
que llevamos es 21 entonces esto es como
menos 21
más o menos y esto de acá le estamos
sumando 12 entonces qué sucede ahora es
negativo entonces aquí para x igual a
3.5 28 déjame ponerlo acá para para que
no quede muy amontonado aquí abajo
entonces para x igual a 3.5 28 obtenemos
que la segunda derivada es menor o igual
que 0 esto está bueno verdad esto nos
dice que hay un máximo máximo porque
gráficamente qué quiere decir esto de
acá y esto de acá quiere decir que
tenemos o sea si la derivada es negativa
entonces quiere la segunda deriva es
negativa quiere decir que la función se
ve así
verdad parece como una volteada hacia
abajo entonces la derivada la primera
derivada empieza muy grande empieza a
bajar ya bajar y a bajar porque la
segunda derivar es negativa y entonces
en efecto el punto crítico es un máximo
eso está bueno vamos a ver qué pasa con
el otro punto verdad a lo mejor también
es máximo y tengamos que compararlos
qué pasa cuando x es igual a 0.4 725
pues aquí es como 0.5 y aquí es menos 6
por 0.56 como menos tres menos tres más
doce pues es algo positivo es como 9
verdad pues aquí la segunda derivada es
mayor o igual que 0
ahora tenemos una función cóncava hacia
abajo perdón cóncava hacia arriba estará
cóncava hacia abajo sabemos que una
cóncava hacia arriba
más o menos algo de este estilo y
entonces ahora qué sucede con las
pendientes las pendientes encías
empiezan siendo negativas pero van
creciendo van creciendo aquí en el punto
crítico son iguales a cero y luego
crecen más entonces aquí tenemos un
mínimo de jale como que es un mínimo y
bueno a esto en particular nos dice que
no nos conviene producir esta cantidad
de miles de zapatos verdad cuando nos
conviene producir esto cuando estén
zapatos si estos son miles son
cuatrocientos sesenta y setenta y dos
pares de zapatos esto definitivamente no
nos compete hacer por que minimizaría
nuestras ganancias y eso está feo verdad
esto es más bien lo que queremos hacer
es adaptarse este valor acá
qué es el valor que nos da el valor
máximo y el valor máximo y bueno una vez
que lo evaluamos entonces tenemos que
hacer esta cantidad de pares de zapatos
es la cantidad de zapatos que tenemos
que producir y finalmente lo único que
tenemos que hacer para ya determinar
pues cuánto vamos a una verdad es la
cantidad de zapatos ahora queremos ver
cuánto vamos a ganar pues es evaluar la
función g la función de x en este valor
bueno déjame hacer eso entonces vamos a
ponerlo por acá vamos a traerlo de este
lado déjame ponerle en color un color
bonito para que se vea que es el máximo
naranja entonces
vamos a evaluar g de 3.528 la ganancia
para cuando producimos 3.528 zapatos y
metiéndolo a la calculadora esto nos da
igual
vamos a ver cuánto nos da vamos a
aprender la calculadora y entonces es
menos menos le pongo paréntesis 3.528
3.528 elevado al cubo ok
más +6 por 3.528 3.528 elevado al
cuadrado muy bien menos menos 5 por 5
por 3.5 28 menos 3.5 8 al cubo más seis
veces 3.528 al cuadrado menos cinco
veces 3.255 3.528 ajá excelente entonces
ahora sí redoble de tambores y picamos
en enter y nos queda 13 puntos 12 84
otra vez como son miles vamos a agarrar
hasta el hasta el 8 entonces nos queda
13.128
esto de acá es igual a 13.128 y
acordándonos que todos en miles de pesos
esto nos dice que vamos a ganar 13 mil
128 pesos ya después de quitar los
costos y todo eso entonces eso está muy
bien ya encontramos el valor máximo y
podemos ser unos productores de zapatos
felices y ricos hasta la próxima